hey guys welcome back to the corridor
digital podcast it's wonderful to be
here can you believe that we are back
only one week after our previous release
I mean oh look at this
we haven't we went from September to
January and now guess what we're back in
a week and here's why because we're
gonna keep these podcasts hot and ready
okay we're not gonna mess around we're
not gonna we're gonna we're gonna just
take them on keep grabbing by the horns
as this roll I talk you talk why don't
you record it that's all right so here's
what we're gonna do today guys we have
to record another one of these with Nico
and we have a short amount of time to do
so so we are officially I've got a timer
here 30 minutes okay now the topic well
should I start the timer now or after
the topic okay we're rolling all right
guys the topic of today is
self-improvement now we get a lot of
questions via email in the comments all
over the place about people asking us
not just how do you make yourself a
better filmmaker but how do you get to a
point in life where you can do what you
want to do and how can you improve
yourself so that when you are doing what
you want to do you can be even better at
it and I thought I thought it would be
interesting today to just take some time
sit down with Sam and Clint and go
through what what we do as individuals
when approaching not just like your work
and your craft and the filmmaking that
we do here but also yourself so
absolutely you know it's it's it's a
very broad topic it in a lot of ways
because you know I feel like
self-improvement comes down to two
elements there's the the goal that you
want to reach and then there's also the
discipline that you need to reach that
goal and I feel like each one is its own
almost a separate conversation because I
have a lot of problem with the latter
the discipline element ever the hardest
part yeah everybody for sure but I also
I can imagine how sometimes it's like
when
the goal setting and the idea of like I
want to reach a certain point and it
like how you get there is just as
difficult as maintaining that discipline
you know so it's interesting that you go
straight to discipline and goal because
I think that that is the first thing in
achieving anything and you'll hear this
across the board when you're talking
about like how do I do better how do I
be better the first thing you need to do
is you need to set a goal and and that
is oftentimes for especially for young
people I know you know when I was
younger like that was the hardest thing
because a goal is ultimately narrowing
your possibilities in life right and
that's almost the scariest thing is like
you're you're like oh well I like music
so Ormeau let's do it more contextually
I like videos so maybe I'll become a
youtuber or a videographer or a
filmmaker well that means that in order
to even set that goal you've all of a
sudden now just taken like just taken
you know like all the other science yeah
or like biology and you've set that and
you're like okay I'm not going towards
that goal yes and that can sometimes be
the hardest step but honestly I think
yeah just just like you might find out
halfway that it's not for you yeah right
but at least you took the halfway at
least you got halfway yeah I'm figuring
and you figured it out and not you know
so there's one little element in the
concept of goals and self-improvement
that I can kind of have like I've got a
first-hand personal family anecdote
about it but like I think a really good
example is so we make videos here we
make youtube videos but also we kind of
got into this for the sake of making
movies and you know cinema inspiring us
and so in a way like I know making
YouTube videos is definitely a huge goal
for a lot of people but for us at the
same time you know doing something
bigger than a YouTube video in
quote-unquote you know
is definitely a huge goal and um in a
few ways I've kind of realized that over
the last few years the way we or the way
I kind of approached the goal of oh
let's make something bigger let's make a
movie or something like this the problem
I was facing was that I had a goal but
the problem I the problem I faced was
that I wasn't approaching that goal from
like a tangible standpoint in the sense
that a lot of people especially when
you're it wouldn't when you're
self-improvement topic a audience around
something you want to do in life or
something you want to accomplish or
something like that frequently you can
turn towards I guess hoping that the
right opportunity presents itself for
you to accept the opportunity and then
reach that goal but the problem is is
that that's not real goal setting so to
speak it's not how real life works it's
not really how real life works
you know and discipline comes in exactly
and the moat that yeah but like it's
there's this there's a lapse there
there's kind of like a gap between you
know where we are and what we're doing
and where that goal is and we're just
hoping there's like the magical question
mark that kind of comes along and goes
oh these talented video artists on
YouTube right the right the top men for
the job
you know and then they you boys you you
have the job and they're like yes we did
it they're making them you know it's
like that mindset really kind of slows
you down and kind of prevents you from
actually accomplishing that kind of
stuff so I've noticed over like the last
two years here I've slowly gotten my
like little meter shifted a little bit
and I think it's made me a little more
productive in all aspects of what we do
I guess but um I guess to really boil
that down it's about breaking down those
steps you need to actually reach that
goal into like really achievable things
that are within your reach and power to
to do so to speak like things that you
can actually you things you can
realistically get done yeah um there's a
like that that totally makes sense to me
like you need to have an actual like
plan on what you're gonna do and
breakdown like if you have a big goal of
I want to make a movie or you know I
want to make a million dollars like okay
how are you gonna do that and pick up
that penny that you see on the
sure yeah yeah although I think you burn
more calories than it takes to make a
penny at this point just by leaning over
and picking it up there's um there's a
book I think the first the first book
that I read that was about you know
improving your yourself was a book by a
guy named Jim Rohn it was called seven
steps to wealth and happiness I think is
it was a book my dad gave me and it's
like 150 pages and it blew my mind
I was like oh my god this is a gold mine
I didn't know there's anything like this
and he explains how like there's a
goal-setting chapter of course right
yeah and in the goal-setting chapter
he's just says well list all the things
that you love doing list all the things
that you want to do and like split those
up into categories of like a one-year
goal two year three or five seven-year
goal and then go through all those go
through all those things and ask
yourself why like why do I want to do
that and if you can come up with a good
reason for you know all the things you
listed out awesome so now you have a
whole bunch of goals and you have a
reason as to why you want to do them and
I think without the reason it's gonna be
kind of tough to to get something done
because if you're just white why am i
doing this every day because eventually
you want to get to the point where
you're doing something and this is just
from personal experience and just
messing around with reading self-help
books and stuff and trying to apply it
to my life you know a whole bunch of
them talk about breaking down stuff
breaking down your goals and doing
something to work towards that goal
every single day so if you take an hour
a day to work on say if you want to make
a movie just work on it an hour a day if
you want to you know make a music video
work on it for an hour a day if you want
to do if you want to save enough money
if you want to make a million bucks work
on you know work on your plan for that
an hour a day and I found that to be
like really really helpful
because you're gonna hit a point where
like you don't want to do it anymore
just like working out no one wants to
work out but when it's done it's the
best and if you just do it for an hour a
day oh man you're gonna be so set up for
the future you know you're investing in
yourself when you're taking the time so
the thing you guys keep going back to is
discipline yeah that is what I'm hearing
you know obviously you can't have a
discipline until you have a goal but
even for people so so that's the first
part is you need to set a goal and then
there's there's an there's any form of
discipline is best I say because it
doesn't matter your goal might be
different I require a different set of
discipline to get to are we good okay it
might require a different set of
discipline to get to but just the
discipline of having it consistent helps
get you there step by step and then
obviously along the way you learn things
you can make improvements but for those
of you out there who might be thinking
well that's great I once I have a goal I
can have discipline I would also say
that it's okay to like say you take
those take those seven steps and you
write down five goals and you write down
five reasons for why you want to achieve
those goals a very real an actual goal I
think what do i what do i what I apply
to my own life is just this idea of like
well I want to be better at something
yeah you know I wanted because even if I
even if I don't know hey you know if
this is what my my life's vocation might
be right say it's like woodworking or
something or like drawing it's like I
know that I know that I want to be
better at it or I know that I want to be
better at something and this is an
outlet to make me better at something
which will cause you to form habits of
discipline which will then cause you to
form evaluations of yourself that then
you can apply more articulately and
accurately to
the goals that you might come up with as
you get better through discipline so
where my mind went when you're saying
that is like if people got into a sport
or like III was huge into martial arts I
also did a little track I know you were
all up about the track right during time
yeah so like yeah that takes discipline
and there's days you don't want to go
track to your track practice or martial
arts but your dad forces you to go son
I'm paying for these classes or go
so let's boil this down to some actual
like what what are some things that you
guys have actually done in the process
of of applying this sort of knowledge to
your own life what's an example man well
like I I don't know if I had its I don't
know if it's the most media example but
um about like in in 2016 I started
getting back into recording music
because I it's a huge passion of mine
and there was like a good like three or
four year lapse where I kind of stopped
making like the music for our YouTube
videos and then so I just stopped doing
that and so after about three years of
like literally not touching an
instrument I was like alright you know I
should kind of figure this out again and
get better at this and so I worked for
about a to two year period just getting
better at playing music and figuring out
how to mix and record stuff better and
so I released an album in 2018 but in a
funny way a lot of the discipline and
goals that kind of went into it other
than just that personal passion was like
that was when Gideon was about to be
born so I was like ah reott here's
here's a good thing to do here my-my-my
like cutoff date is basically when he's
born I mean I like I I'm going to work
my ass off to like get this done and say
I did it before that point
yeah and that was a really that was just
a simple like a deadline thing you know
what I mean and like thankful you was
not like an imaginary deadline like
Tuesday and then what happens Wednesday
it's like well I could still work on it
Wednesday it's like know that I was
realistically facing a kind of like a
wall of time you know that I couldn't
you know cross yeah and that really that
really helps a functional dead
like what something with meaning I guess
and so what did did you like have a
thing where you went well you went home
every night and you were like okay for
45 minutes I'm going to just play and
record and then or did you like
basically basically I was just like
alright I'm gonna you know on on
weekends maybe I'll like dude for like
two to three hours and then on weekdays
if I have the time or energy when I get
back I'll try and do that and so that
that kind of routine of just making it
constant was great thankfully you
something I really enjoy doing unlike
the many other tasks you usually have to
do to reach a goal yeah you know I mean
like there wasn't like a lot of
paperwork I had to do or I didn't have
to get on the phone for like one of
those hours every week learning the
instrument or well I mean actually I did
have to relearn a lot of stuff and learn
new things but and I just went through
that process again so I'm gonna release
another album now in like a month or so
maybe two months I will see one Casey
wraps it up but you know baby number two
is on the way so I've been able to
repeat that same process nice okay so so
how let's let's let's go a level deeper
here when you had Gideon how did you
find time now after Gideon to work on
your second album was way way harder way
harder and I wouldn't I
I maybe worked on it during the day like
a handful of times at this point you
know if he's sleeping taking a nap
during the day on a weekend like I'll do
it but right now it's mostly like I do
it from like 10 to 11:30 p.m. at night
he goes to sleep and then I've got like
this tiny window right where I'm awake
enough to work on it and not like kill
myself the next day yeah you know and
lose enough sleep over it and so
basically every other day at this point
I just have this hour window to work on
it and that's just it's kind of like
that that one hour yeah you know one
hours a week though mm-hmm which adds up
you know by 10 it does 12 leaves and now
you're talking significant amounts of
time yeah and so like once again I it
this is what I'm saying it's not the
most meaty example necessarily but it
because I think ultimately it's always
easier when you are really enjoying an
passionately and like enjoying the steps
that it takes to reach that goal and you
can kind of see immediate progress I
think that's a very real example though
because most people aren't just waking
up in the morning and going oh my god I
have all this free time and energy what
should I learn no one's waking up doing
that you know I think you have you have
a life you have a job you have you have
to make ends meet you have to do all
sorts of things now making the time you
have to like force yourself to make the
time to do something and you can find an
hour you can find an hour and like I
think like what Sam was saying is that
you found those those hours in the week
and you kept it consistent and I think
that is like one of the most important
things is consistency
because if you don't have consistency if
you workout once or twice here and there
you're not I mean that's gonna do any
good right but or if you save money here
and there just once or twice like yeah
and it's like the same thing for
personal growth like if you have to be
consistent if you're really trying to
get something done or if you're really
trying to work on something or remember
something you need to work on it once a
week once a week you know if you if it's
east like right now I'm working out once
a week and like hopefully I can get to
the point where I can go twice a week
three times a week I recently did a
website for my photography I needed a
place for my photography that wasn't
just my Instagram yeah and it wasn't
gonna do it itself right so I was like I
got to make a website I don't know
anything about websites there's like
this big boulder go to squarespace.com
slash corridor crew and get under center
for first purchase I I should have I
should have oh no oh I researched I
researched all the different stuff and
another one works better so Squarespace
the sponsor anyway the point the point
is it was a big boulder to push up the
hill and I had to just be like you know
what an hour a day I'm gonna invest the
time to figure it out what's the first
thing or how do I make a good website I
don't know what are my options look at
all the different options okay what are
other people doing that I like or
dislike
so then I spend an hour looking up that
and then the rest of the hours in the
morning is like doing it and learning
the program and like learning the
software and how the you know how to do
the website and referencing the other
websites yeah but it's the consistency
and it would have happened if I wasn't
consistent about it though just so once
you're in there then probably would have
happened right yeah I think that's sort
of this for me - I would I have
different examples but the the iteration
the reiteration of the idea that you
have to find find the time and then you
have to make short Sprint's at it each
time you do is is consistent across like
both what I'm working on in my personal
life and what we're working on here yeah
it's funny Sam and I and Nico did this
breakdown of like time remember I had
you guys yeah you that yeah of like
where you think you spend your time and
on what what content and all that stuff
and I didn't my breakdown and it was
really weird cuz it was it was like 10%
of everything was like no 10% 10% it was
like all these different things that
we're working on here and and I realized
that I was I was I was kind of doing
this with with them with the stuff here
at the studio as well without even
thinking about it but it was like it's
this idea that like you know how do you
I've heard it I've heard the metaphor a
hundred different ways but one of them
is like how do you eat an elephant well
you just you just take a bite of it yeah
you just take a bite and so yeah that's
the same thing applies here I think as
well as personal life like I'm doing the
workout thing like I've got a routine
now with like Wendy and and you know
it's like four days a week five days a
week there's basically two days a week
that I take off and then sometimes
Sundays that's great and then that's it
and then and then I'm trying to get
through this this this this history
novel this Civil War thing that I've
been reading for like two years
oh you got your self imposed deadline
okay yes so now exactly I have a
deadline I have a goal and now I'm
driving at that go hard because I so
I've made the mistake perhaps of I was
watching the Ken Burns documentary on
the Civil War
and there's this guy Shelby Foote who's
this like
sort of like charming like southern
historian I was like this guy's kind of
cool like I wonder who this guy is and I
looked him up and it was like oh he's
done all these works and like the Civil
War is like this great volume is this
three volume thing that he wrote or he
like went through the hundreds and
hundreds of pages of actual
conversations between generals and like
letters to home and like apparently the
United States government has an entire
rack has entire records of this that is
like open and available to the public
and he went through all of it well I
like wrote the Civil War what's his name
Shelby Foote thanks Shelby Foote yeah
yeah and so I but I started and I didn't
really have a goal and I was like I like
this history I like history and my goal
I guess is to like understand more about
what happened in this war and so that
was my goal but that's a really bad goal
you know and so I kind of was reading
and I pick it up and then I put it down
and I'd read it on an airplane and I'd
go through like 50 pages and then I put
it down again for a couple of weeks and
or a couple days you know and it took me
like 18 months to get through the first
volume was this page yeah the first
volume was 900 pages and now I'm totally
reasonable amount of time to go through
ok but but what I realize is now so I've
had to sacrifice a couple of books that
I wanted to read and a couple other
things that I've wanted to do in the
interim because I management because
I've got this short term goal that I'm
trying to hit with this book but I'm
going to Gettysburg in February for a
weekend and I'm gonna visit Gettysburg
so hold on earlier late this is this
just a civil war trip like no well also
my it's my cousin's 50th birthday and
I'm gonna see my brother they live there
in Gettysburg they live an hour from
Gettysburg yeah oh wow yeah that's
convenient so I didn't realize this and
I originally wedding I originally
planned the trip and we were like hey
we're gonna go we're gonna go for and
she's 50th is Berg the eighties but
where do i yeah and then
the math but I was like wait a minute
Gettysburg told me an hour from I'm in
volume 2 right now I just started volume
2 because I was kind of intimidated by
volume 2 because volume 2 is a thousand
pages in volume 3 is 1,200 pages and I
haven't even gotten to that do you'll
break a sweat looking at buoyant and I
started volume 2 January 1st and I and I
just crossed page 450 already out of how
many out of 900 but Gettysburg happens
at at between 500 and 650 and so I'm
definitely on pace to make it alright so
you look forward you flash-forward
yesall okay so I am on pace to make and
get through Gettysburg by the time that
I get to Gettysburg and that's only
possible if you just only possible if I
read 20 pages a night whoa
all right it's doable but you got that
time management right I'm ahead right
now good night i read 35 pages well you
know you might be even better to see
what happens after Gettysburg a little
bit so while you're there yes mm-hmm
I see why I see the repercussions here
you have to finish volume 2 and you
might as well finish volume 3 both let
me go I might as well fine yeah I got to
get to the Gettysburg Address which
doesn't happen until page 800 dude I
just got to get as far as I can you can
order your best right you got a lady
Brazilian your breasts the reason and so
the thing that so just back to shelby
foote for a second and why I've set this
goal in the first place we have seven
minutes left I found him interesting and
I wanted to read his book because when I
was watching the Ken Burns documentary
he said the Civil War was the thing that
I changed Americans from saying the
United States are going to do something
to the United States is going to do
something new and that was when I
thought what happened here these United
States
yes are going to do something snap
versus the United States is a singular
noun yeah
that is a fantastic statement there we
go had some some good stuff so that is
effectively what that war was well some
boiled down into a sentence which I just
thought I've never heard anyone boil
down such a crazy and influential
historical event like that and so I had
released changes from why you changed
your perception of what the United
States is Wow our that's dealer that's
huge
like when's the last time something that
big has happened I mean it's happening
everyday in little ways but you know
yeah there's that's that's intense
so anyway that was that was what I've
that was my goal and now that I have a
goal goal and I can see the finish line
I'm like dude I'm I've got that pedal
down and I'm just Clint did you set the
deadline for your stuff because that we
we we had deadlines yes and you had a
deadline how did you come up with your
deadline um Black Friday Black Friday
well there you go
it was my deadline I wanted to be in
shape for the Black Friday sales
yes well for the website oh sorry yeah
for the website yeah that makes sense
though I mean like we all kind of have
like pretty clear deadlines associated
with this this kept these goals yes
which is really helpful but I'm trying
to think of like you know like when you
don't have something tangible associated
with your deadline yes
what's is is there something you guys
use cuz a lot of these goals we set for
ourselves you know that they don't have
there's you know there's no way to
really functionally create a deadline
for them like so how do you how do you
do that um thing comes down to priority
honestly because for example one of my
goals is to eventually figure out how to
record music better because I want to
write like Civil War no I want western
songs
yeah and so I got myself a banjo and I
but but I don't know anything well I
don't
a little bit I don't know enough about
recording music to do it correctly so
that I can just post songs like Sam does
which is eventually my goal it's easy
what I haven't I can tell you I can just
tell you all the things you need to know
well I haven't said it my point is I
haven't set a goal yet you write your
goal your priority your goal priority is
still so low that you haven't even asked
me for advice which I can easily give to
you that's true see ya so how do I do
this we have three and four minutes left
well I mean I can tell you right here
yeah tell me all right
so recording music comes down to like
four main things that you need to figure
out what like you need to figure out
what your recording software is going to
be okay because that's ultimately how
you're gonna manipulate the audio files
don't may be yours maybe you've chosen
that hopefully but after my advice
you'll probably switch Chios
yeah Cubase is great so you need to
figure out how what software you're
gonna use you're gonna need to figure
out how you want to get your audio
signals into your computer there's a
million easy ways we do it all here
there's plenty of these little boxes
audio interfaces etc no no no no we're
not there yet oh we're at the computer
so you like the the files where you need
like the actual box and if I understand
how that works then you need to figure
out what kind of instrument you're gonna
be recording if it's a live instrument
that's boom you got a banjo and then the
last step is here if your microphone and
basically once you have your those core
things figured out then basically you
just want to make sure you're in a good
space to record it you want to figure
out how to process the footage you use
utilizing that software you have there's
a lot of there's the old-fashioned ways
of mixing things with eq's and things
like that but there's a lot of tools
that have come out recently they'll let
that allow you to basically just use
presets there's a pack I use frequently
called ez mix it's literally called ez
mix and basically when you don't want a
sip sound spend time fiddling with like
the eq and like a mix on a certain
instrument you literally can pull
presets like oh this is a piano so it
just slaps on like a basic like piano eq
Alexa tell me how to mix my job no no
but this that this kind of stuff speeds
up all the junk you don't want to really
deal with as far as like you know yeah
oh how do I make my now that I have my
mic and my banjo and my software in my
audio box like I don't
it actually sound good other than just
capturing it right and there's there's
there's two paths you can use these kind
of presets or you can manual or
automatic I've kind of into the manual
which is I feel like you get into that
after you start with the presets I think
it right in the way things are working
right now definitely you can definitely
do that like you go you know what I'd
rather not use the Instagram filters and
color grade everything I post from
scratch without knowing anything about
color great get posting first yeah
here's the thing there's this is the
goal-setting thing which is do you want
to get really good at mixing and
mastering first or do you want to create
a bunch of material that you can mix and
mash right you know in life and it's and
when you're recording music it's always
way better when you record it and it
already sounds pretty good and you're
like cool I don't need to like cringe
upon my first recording so my last
question there did you play the dulcimer
on some of my tracks would I all had
depends I mean yeah I mean yes I would
offer up that that thing I'd play a
dulcimer okay cool the way you phrased
it it's like what is I oh well would you
yeah sure yeah of course you would Sam
Sam's good yeah no not very good my way
of playing it cool great I got one thing
yeah one thing nice thing generally in
terms of self-improvement right yeah
books man freaking books man I would
love to just curate a little list of
books in the description yes yes yeah
for people to just look at and like I'm
sure you guys have books too so yeah
I've got it yeah we should just throw
down like some books a little
description on what it is and maybe 15
or some say a few out loud
mastery a key guy is like Japanese
philosophy on following your passion and
doing a thing turning pro by Steven
Pressfield words the hurt words that
he'll there's a whole discipline equals
freedom that's our timer
there's discipline equals freedom by
Jaakko will Nick there's the 4-hour
workweek by Tim
Phares that one's okay there's on
managing people by the Harvard
University Press mmm that one's got that
one's pretty useful and then uh what
other ones have I blasted through oh and
then there's the classic how to win
friends and influence people by Dale
Carnegie yeah which I rejected for the
longest time because of the title and
the name Carnegie was involved and I was
like this is [ __ ]
yeah that book isn't a little yeah
actually it's um hits on some really
important fundamentals yep agreed I also
can't hurt me by David Goggins yeah
really good and anything
Jordan B Peterson twelve rules for life
I don't read a lot of books I read that
one I thought was cool I was like yeah I
need stuff in here is it yeah we'll just
do a whole description alright so once
again thanks for watching the corridor
cast guys consider subscribing if you
are not but seeing as how you're one of
probably a hundred thousand people who
are subscribed to this podcast thank you
for being subscribed you are what we
call the true tonn's
you are the truest of the croutons yeah
and if any of you guys have goals out
there feel free to setting them right
now
put him on a priority list maybe take a
cool maybe yours better at goal-setting
just bump that priority good I don't
know you should wait 30 minutes hour a
day yeah go out make a movie real quick
alright well we hope you guys learn
something have a great day Thanks peace